el valor máximo de la expresión 1 / seno
cuadrado detecta más tres veces seno de
teta por ccoo se no detecta más 5 x
kosher no cuadra de teta es lo primero
que voy a hacer es tratar de simplificar
esta expresión así que volvamos a
escribirla quizás aquí abajo 1 /
seno cuadrado de teta seno cuadrado de
teta y cada vez que veo un seno cuadra
de teta mi mente automáticamente busca
un coste no cuadra de teta porque yo sé
que se no cuadra beteta más coseno
cuadrado teta siempre vale 1 y aquí no
sólo tengo un coste no cuadra beteta
tengo cinco de ellos así que déjenme me
robó uno el robo 1 para escribir más
coseno cuadra de teta
si me robe 1 me quedan cuatro así que
más cuatro veces coseno cuadrado de teta
más tres veces el seno de teta por el
coseno de teta
bien y vamos a continuar simplificando
esta expresión para empezar 12 que aquí
se nos cuadra de teta más coste no
cuadra beteta como decía antes
esto vale 1
así que vamos a escribir esto como 1 /
1 / cuanto pues va a ser uno esté uno
aquí más cuatro veces coseno cuadra
beteta ahora yo sé yo sé déjenme lo
escribo por acá que de nuestros vídeos
de trigonometría jose no cuadra beteta
cose no cuadra beteta es igual a uno más
coseno de dos tetas
entre 2
1 + coseno de 2 t está entre 2
y entonces puedo sustituir este 4 coseno
cuadra beteta por 4 veces estoy acá pero
cuánto es eso de ahí 4 veces esto sería
lo mismo que 2
dos más dos veces coseno de dos tetas
digamos esto fue este caso de aquí
ahora más tres veces que no detecta por
coseno de teta
estas de aquí pues ahora yo sé qué seno
de dos tetas
es igual a dos veces el seno de teta por
el coste no de teta
así que si divido esta expresión entre 2
obtengo que un medio de el seno de 2 t
está
es igual a el seno de teta por el coseno
de teta
así que si sustituyo esto acá obtendría
más tres veces perdón tres medios tres
medios porque es tres por un medio tres
medios por seno de dos zetas
bien así que ya vamos mejorando y el
objetivo de hacer esto es que lo que voy
a querer hacer es si quiera maximizar
esta fracción eso equivale a minimizar
el denominador así que quiero
simplificar la y después quizás usar
cálculo o algo así bien entonces esto lo
puede escribir como 1 /
1 entre 12 estrés
más dos veces coseno de dos tetas más
tres medios tres medios de seno de dos
teta y entonces lo que estoy buscando lo
que estoy buscando es el mínimo el
mínimo
de esta expresión el mínimo de tres más
dos veces coseno de dos tetas más tres
medios de seno de dos teta
el mínimo de xto expresión se
correspondería con el máximo de esta así
que esto es igual a el mínimo y lo único
que voy a hacer es sustituir dos teta
por equis simplemente para hacer las
cuentas más fáciles tres más dos veces
coseno de x tres más dos veces coseno de
x más tres medios seno
de x bien así que quiero minimizar esto
y para ello vamos a usar cálculo bien
pues la derivada de esto quiero obtener
la derivada de esto es igualar la a cero
y la derivada de esto sería la derivada
de 13-0 la derivada de dos por coseno de
x es igual a menos dos seno de x menos
20 de x más tres medios
tres medios la derivada del seno de x es
cosa de x seno de x y esto lo quiero
igualar a cero esto nos daría ya sea un
máximo o un mínimo donde la pendiente de
la tangente es nula pero después voy a
tener que determinar qué valores si es
un máximo o es un mínimo perfecto
entonces y aquí puede escribir esto como
tres medios por el coseno de x es igual
a dos veces el seno de x ahora voy a
dividir todo entre dos y me quedaría
tres cuartos de coseno de x es igual a
es igual a seno de x y ahora dividido
todo entre coseno y obtengo que tres
cuartos es igual a seno de x / coseno de
x pero quién es esta expresión tiene
seno de x entre costa no x pues ustedes
ya saben que esto es tangente de x bien
así que el valor mínimo o máximo se
alcanza cuando la tangente x vale 3
entre 4 y cuando sucede eso pues vamos a
tratar de graficar vamos a tratar de ver
cómo funciona esto así que
voy a tratar de dibujar un círculo
unitario
un círculo comunitario
algo así y déjenme pongo mi círculo
aquí vamos a decir que eso es un círculo
unitario perfecto entonces los valores
de la tangente como puede encontrar una
equis donde la tangente valga tres
cuartos estoy buscando un ángulo con el
eje positivo pues de hecho tangente es
igual a cateto opuesto / adyacente así
que si dibujo aquí un triángulo un
triángulo rectángulo
entonces este este cateto tendría que
valer si esto es x este cateto tendría
que valer 3 y éste tendría que valer 4 y
espero que reconozcan esto como un
triángulo 345 es decir la hipotenusa
vale 5 eso es muy fácil de calcular 3 al
cuadrado más 4 al cuadrado es igual a 9
16 que es 25 y 5 al cuadrado es 25 así
que es un triángulo de esta forma aunque
aquí la hipotenusa no es unitaria no
vale 1 pero puedo corregir eso sólo
tengo que dividir todo entre 5
así que veamos
si / todo entre 5 la hipotenusa baldía 1
el cateto opuesto valdría tres quintos
tres quintos y el cateto adyacente
valdría cuatro quintos
esto sería x
pero en este caso el coseno y el seno
son positivos de modo que esta expresión
está quizás no minimizada sino
maximizada en este punto pero
afortunadamente hay otro lugar donde la
tangente vale tres cuartos y ese es si
prolongó esta recta del otro lado se
correspondería con este ángulo con todo
este ángulo y aquí la tangente también
vale tres cuartos en este caso la
coordenada x que corresponde con el
coche no vale menos cuatro quintos
y la coordenada jake que corresponde al
seno valdría menos tres quintos así que
esta es la que probablemente minimice
esta función de hecho también podría
haber usado la prueba la segunda
derivada a checar si la segunda derivada
es positiva entonces esto se corresponde
con un mínimo y si la segunda derivada
es negativa se corresponde con un máximo
pero en este caso puedo adivinar de aquí
directamente y noten que no me están
pidiendo encontrar el valor de x o de
theta para el cual se satisface esto
solo me están pidiendo encontrar este
máximo así que con estos valores con
estos valores ya puedo resolver mi
problema porque yo sé que para este
valor de x el coste no vale menos cuatro
quintos y el seno vale menos tres
quintos
así que si sustituyó a que obtendría
no tendría tres más dos veces el seno de
x por el coseno de x es menos cuatro
quintos
mis cuatro quintos
más tres medios del seno de x que sería
tres medios
por tres quintos menos tres quintos
y esto cuanto vale pues es tres menos
ocho quintos
- nueve décimos
y esto si lo pongo en denominador como
un 10
esto sería 30
30 - 16 menos 9 todo entre 10 y esto
sencillamente es 30 menos 16 a 14 menos
955 decimos cinco décimos y cinco
decimos cuánto es pues cinco décimos es
simplemente un medio así que el valor
mínimo de esta expresión es es un medio
pero entonces cuál es el valor máximo de
esta expresión pues sería uno entre un
medio que es simplemente dos y ya
acabamos